you know those mornings when you wake up
and you're so like drunk that is 100%
where I'm at right now was wrong dance
okay so I met this dude who was living
in Prague and you told me that every
morning the first thing you'd do me woke
up was dance with reckless abandon like
no one's watching said help with his
self-confidence make him feel less
awkward silly because he did the
silliest thing you could think of in the
morning the challenge Brenda Jaden Eric
and myself to do the same thing we're
gonna dance reckless abandon for three
songs every morning for five days and we
put together a little playlist for each
of us on Spotify which you can get in
the description below this is gonna be
awkward as hell let's do this alright so
I just woke up and I'm actually really
excited I'm ready to do this time to get
up and dance
[Music]
oh yeah time that was a great way to
wake up I feel freaking amazing feeling
today mine like that
I feel like today the cat's in this
freaking onesie are giving me older
power
oh no breaker where just breath day last
night and I am massive today to dance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
warrior dances they were the hub may
help hangers the cure
[Music]
was it
[Music]
it helps you defeat the one obstacle
your mom and you ma you crazy crazy it's
very freeing it's very freeing to dance
and not care what anyone thinks of you
cuz you can tell about my dance moves
I'm not dancing for style dance it for
me I think this is the toughest workout
have had of this so far man this is
gonna be a fun little goodbye dance to
you guys but I'm gonna keep dancing so
[Music]
man it's definitely a fun way to workout
definitely a fun way to keep your
resolution going I might keep this up I
really really truly recommend this
challenge I think you should try and do
something in the morning that's positive
and wakes you up anything that puts you
in a good mood make sure to do it in the
morning because that's what starts off
the rest of your day and the comfort of
your bedroom you can dance like a fool
dance like nobody's watching just like
Kevin - what makes you happy dancing is
exercise dude look out of breath or ham
of course I'm gonna I think I'm gonna
keep doing this maybe not so much like
every day but well no it's maybe maybe
who knows
[Music]